so my daddy glamour story is uh I know I
got Morgan Freeman was making a show
recently talking about his films and so
Danny was like Danny was going good to
see but it's good to see I met his
grandson at Andy's your brother said
funny yeah your brother's is funny so
Morgan Freeman Morgan Freeman told a
story on this show that he was doing
that with Danny Danny Glover had seen
Shawshank Redemption and had come to him
to tell him how much he enjoyed
Shawshank Redemption and he was Morgan
it was so good in this room from
production I'm sorry the script wrap
you're telling me I'm in the shrimp
shrimp production the shrimp shrimp
production I was not aware that I did
two movies last year here's Jordan peels
and I'll let you do your Dania I know
I'm tripling up so it appeals Danny
Glover this is Jordan close Danny Glover
and he didn't a two-man show about 20
years ago hbhb
[Laughter]
he says Popeye seventy four times in
three seconds
to the little boy because he's trying to
see if someone has a tattoo like Martin
Riggs tattoo